if you thought House of the Dragon  couldn't get any crazier than honey  you've got a big storm coming the Iron  Throne sits empty as Otto Hightower  announces the death of King viserys in  the episode 8 subtitles we did see that  the king's breathing had stopped now I  should mention the name of this episode  is the green Council and here we see  Allison along with Otto and Sir  Christian at the head of the small  Council the greens of course refers to  Allison's side in the upcoming civil war  known as the dance of dragons rhaenyra's  side is known as the blacks here we see  Allison in the dead of night she'd  obviously want to tell her father the  interpretation of what the king said  shortly before his death now in the  trailer she flat out says the king said  he wanted aegon to be king this may be  what she wanted to hear but the king  never said those words I do think in  Allison's mind she believes this is what  the king wanted but that doesn't make it  true